une récompense qui va changer son
existence il y a quatre ans gaëtan
maurice commencé son c'est râpé de
boulanger entre cours au cfa de chartres
et apprentissage dans cette boulangerie
à dreux aujourd'hui à 20 ans il est
meilleur apprenti boulanger de france
c'est une très grande fierté c'est un
rêve
vraiment c'est un rêve depuis que j'ai
commencé l'apprentissage dès que j'ai
fini là la troisième voie l'a fait j'ai
commencé à faire ce métier là et je suis
toujours dedans et ça me plaît toujours
autant
là c'est les pins kong les frags lé
grand nord
son patron a vu défiler une quarantaine
d'apprentis depuis qu'il a ouvert sa
boulangerie mais par son
professionnalisme et sa ténacité
gaëtan a su devenir un motif de fierté
revenir avec le col bleu blanc rouge
c'est énorme
nous on est content pour les très très
content c'est sûr qu'il arrivait avec
plein d'idées on essaie de le canaliser
un petit peu pour pas qu'ils fassent
tout et n'importe quoi parce qu'on s'est
quand même c'est un cas un concours
prestigieux donc on essayait de voilà de
de l'aiguillé depuis qu il est lauréat
le jeune apprenti est constamment
sollicité par des entreprises en france
et à l'étranger
cette récompense devrait donner un coup
de pouce à sa carrière pense pas qu'elle
change mes envies mais elles vont me
donner beaucoup plus d'opportunités
je vais je pense que je vais avoir
beaucoup plus de chances de trouver un
emploi d'avoir des banques qui me
suivent pour après a vraiment
d'entreprise et déjà un nouvel objectif
pour gaëtan mon rêve à être meilleurs
ouvriers de france
à plus court terme gaëtan maurice
souhaite passer un brevet de maîtrise
pour devenir un jour chef d'entreprise